-I haven't seen you,
because last time I saw you,
we were Zooming on our show.
-That's right.
Yeah, that's right.
-And you were about to film
"Halston" in New York City.
-Oh, yeah.
-And everything got shut down.
-How is it to be back,
with the audience and such?
-It's the greatest thing.
Doesn't it feel great?
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's totally night and day.
-The Roots, the band.
-The Roots. Everyone's here.
It's night and day.
-Fantastic.
-I want to say congrats,
'cause you ended up
resuming filming.
-Can I say congrats to Questlove
for his documentary?
-Oh, yeah.
-[ Cheers and applause ]
-Beautiful.
-I mean, of course,
congratulations to Questlove.
But congratulations to you.
You won an Emmy for "Halston."
-Oh, yeah.
-Come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on.
-It's nice. But he made
a really beautiful film.
-He did, yeah.
-That was pretty impressive.
-You know, every time you're
on the show, I eventually start
to talk to you
about motorcycles,
'cause I'm interested in them,
and you did a very dangerous
stunt for us one time.
-That's right!
-Yeah. Remember that one?
-I loved -- I had forgotten
all about that. That's right.
-We should put that on --
back on YouTube,
'cause that was
really dangerous.
-I jumped over --
I attempted a very dangerous --
You were talking about --
-Don't try this at home.
-You were talking
about Tom Cruise earlier.
-Yeah. Doing his own stunts.
-Well, I've never seen Tom
Cruise do something like this.
-Yeah.
-I jumped over
an Obi-Wan Kenobi doll.
-Yeah.
A tiny figurine,
like, about that size.
-Yeah. On a -- on a motorcycle.
-On a motorcycle.
-It was about that size.
-Yeah.
And I'm not sure if you
jumped over it or through it.
But either way, you kind of...
The wheel had maybe
this much clearance.
-Yeah.
-It was amazing.
And we put it in slow motion.
-I got all those different
angles and stuff.
-You did. You put a lot
of work into that.
-Anouk did it with me,
my little kid.
We had like, different --
We had an iPad and two phones.
And we edited it in slow motion.
-I loved it.
-Oh, it was great.
-We'll tweet about it
'cause it was actually worth it.
It was so good.
But I -- I never wanted --
I never --
Well, I never have asked you,
what got you into motorcycles?
Was it, like -- Do you remember
your first motorcycle?
-I remember the first time
I rode one, but I think
I was already -- I used to watch
old Elvis Presley movies.
-Yeah.
-My favorite film,
even as a little kid,
was "The Great Escape,"
and Steve McQueen --
I had one of those wind-up
Evel Knievel toys.
-Yes.
-You remember that?
-Sure, and you pull
the rip thing, and it'd go --
-And off it goes.
So -- I don't know.
The motorcycle was, like,
already an object of desire
to me, I guess.
-Yeah.
-And then my dad was --
was the chairman of this
charity organization called
the Round Table in Crieff,
where I come from.
And he -- he did this thing
where he --
local kids would write to him,
and he'd like -- you know --
Somebody wanted
to ride a motorbike,
and he would make that happen.
So we went down.
I went with him.
-That's nice.
-And then this little kid
got to ride around -- and
I was just a little kid, too --
on this little motorbike.
Like, a little 50cc
twist-and-go bike.
And after he'd finished
and went home,
my dad said,
"Do you want a go?"
And I -- I just --
My life changed on that moment,
'cause I never got over --
I never got over it.
-Really?
-I'm still the same now.
Like I'm -- I get on my bike.
I'm like,
"Are they letting me do this?"
Like, "Am I allowed to do...?"
-Really, yeah.
-It feels so much fun,
it should be illegal, really,
riding a motorbike.
-Yeah.
I mean, I could never
be that guy.
I'm more of a person that sits
in the truck and watches.
-In your electric truck.
-In the -- yeah, in the fr--
If I park it,
I could sit in the frunk
and watch you ride.
'Cause it's just rad.
-It's cool.
Me and Charlie, did --
My mate and I did a trip
from the bottom of South America
to L.A. on electric motorbikes.
-Oh, yeah!
-Yeah, a long way up.
I think we talked about it.
-We did. How was it?
Did you feel --
-It was good.
It was --
The bikes are beautiful.
Plugging them in, in Patagonia
is an issue,
'cause there's nowhere
to plug them in, but...
-If I'm next to you
in the truck,
you could plug in and charge it!
-I could plug in your frunk!
-Dude, come on, bud.
-Come on. Let's do another one.
-I'm there for you!
I am there for you!
[ Applause ]
Let's talk about the --
your new "Star Wars" series,
"Obi-Wan Kenobi."
I mean, I'm freaking out!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Fans are freaking out
everywhere.
-Yeah.
-This is your first time back
as Obi-Wan Kenobi in 17 years.
Does that make sense?
-Yeah, the -- We finished
the third one in 2003.
-Oh, my goodness.
-So it's a long time ago.
But it was so fun.
It was just like -- I went --
The first thing I had to do
was go and do, like, a --
I had to read with other actors
for two roles.
And there was like six actors.
So we borrowed
"The Mandalorian" set
and we went in on a Sunday
when they had a day off.
And they had a bit of their set,
and their crew were there.
And I -- I went down,
and there was --
I went to this dressing room,
and there was this sort of
Obi-Wan-esque costume, you know?
They'd thrown --
sort of cobbled it together.
-Yeah.
-And I put it on, and that was
kind of breathtaking, after 17
years, looking in the mirror.
But then I went on and I started
reading with these other actors,
and I totally didn't have
his voice at all.
It was really bad.
I was just doing this sort of
vague English accent,
and it didn't sound at all
like Obi-Wan Kenobi.
-So, all the crew were like...
-Yeah.
-..."Who the heck is this guy?"
-They were quite excited
when I walked on.
I could feel that they were
quite excited.
But then they were
immediately disappointed.
[ Laughter ]
-But then you went --
you went --
-And I had to do some homework.
I just had to go back,
and, like,
watch lots of
Alec Guinness movies
and watch all
the original films and...
I got back into it.
It was good.
It was really good fun.
-You do something that I heard
that's very funny.
You sometimes do, like,
a Jedi-type hand move,
where you pretend
to use the Force,
but just for your own amusement.
Do you know what I'm talking
about? Like, like --
-Yeah, I know,
like, an automatic door.
I can't help myself.
-Dude, I would freak out if I --
Yeah. [ Laughs ]
You go to the grocery store?
-In the airport or something.
You know, there's always like --
In the airport,
there's always automatic doors.
I always -- I always do it
for myself, but...
[ Laughter ]
But I also hope somebody
sees me do it, you know?
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Next time
you see Ewan McGregor,
see if you can see him do it.
There's lots more to talk about.
I want to show a clip
from "Obi-Wan Kenobi."
More with Ewan McGregor
when we come back.
Stick around, everybody.